[Music]
[Applause]
and also with reaction joining us now
Fox News terrorism analyst Dr wed farz
the director of jihad watch Robert
Spencer and from the center for
immigration studies Steve camarada is
with us guys all right let me put up on
the screen um exactly the numbers that
we're looking at in Europe there's been
a lot of immigration there uh the number
of Muslims for example living in Europe
in 2010 well there you have the number
in France 4.7 but let's go to uh the
number living in Europe total which is
44.1 million 6% of the population and if
you look at the projected number by 2030
58.2 million Robert Spencer um you're an
expert you study this when you look at
the numbers of people it's estimated
about 10% of the population of France
the nogo neighborhoods how they have
separated themselves they're not
assimilating um they even separate
Sharia courts do you believe believe
this has contributed to what happened
yesterday oh absolutely Sean there's no
doubt about it whatsoever because in
those enclaves and remember there are
751 of them all over France and that's
not just rumor or conjecture that's
based on a French government website
that lists them all these 751 nogo areas
are essentially ruled by Sharia law they
have no regard for French law they do
not teach French law they inculcate
Sharia and what Sharia teaches is
somebody who Blas FES and insults
Muhammad must be put to death two of the
three Shooters at the Charlie hebo
offices were raised born and raised in
France they grew up in these areas and
they learned that blasphemers must be
put to death that's what they were
acting upon when they went into the
Charlie haveo offic you know I want you
to be very clear on this Rowan Scarboro
in the Washington Times had a great
piece on it today and he described it as
growing islamist Min States in other
words that there is no French Authority
so ostensibly you have a country or many
countries with within a country why
would the French have allowed that to
happen
absolutely well see Islamic law is a
political system as well as a religious
one and it has a complete system for the
governance of society and the political
or social order and so the immigrants
that the French have been bringing in as
well as other European States and the UK
they many of them have come believing
that because the Quran says Muslims are
the best of people and that non-muslims
the most vile of created beings that the
French government and Society has no
value and has to be replaced ultimately
with Sharia and in the meantime Muslims
will set up these separate enclaves
where Sharia Will Rule and the law of
the land will be completely disregarded
this is just a recipe for disaster
because with the growing populations The
Immigrant populations growing there's
just going to be a clash inevitably
between them and the non-muslims yeah
because they're very they're they're
contrary values they're conflicting
values Steve camarado from a from an
immigration standpoint which is which is
where you're coming from so you're
talking about 44.1 million Muslims right
there right now an estimated what 58
million Muslims that they expect by 2030
then the question has to arise if they
don't want to assimilate they want
separate neighborhoods they want
separate court systems they don't even
want help from the police or the fire
department but yet they get to vote why
would France why would these countries
in Europe then allow them to come to
their countries cuz I said they want to
change them and they have values that
conflict with Western values no it's a
very important question immigration is
often just thought of as about dollars
and cents taxes paid or labor markets
but there are these other profound and
important questions cultural questions
or questions about National Security and
unfortunately we don't really ask those
questions here remember the Muslim
population United States is smaller but
growing very rapidly it's about 3
million people now about 100,000 new
Muslim immigrants enter the United
States each year and we have no
discussion about any of the possible
National Security implications a kind of
political correctness rules here and
unfortunately there as well now there
are things we could do to probably
better assimilate people but the bottom
line is immigration is a discretionary
policy we can decide who to let it or
not and we don't even ask yeah while
lead oh we're losing him uh Steve I'm
sorry about that W FZ let me bring you
into this here so in spite of all the
accommodations that the French had made
the Bel have made the the British have
made so if people are coming from Muslim
countries and they believe in Sharia
values contrary to Western values the
antithesis of these values um then it
raises the question about the United
States do we have to examine the values
of people and ascertain those values
before they come here well first of all
Sean in Europe and of course later on in
North America and in Australia when
these communities migrate uh they
migrate as communities and within the
communities you have all sorts of trend
so when those enclaves are established
it's like any ethnic Enclave here in the
United States or in Canada problem is
who is mobilizing who is indoctrinating
who is forcing or pushing these enclaves
to refuse law order to become a noo Zone
I would call for a better understanding
of the networks who are in control it's
not just States many states there is a
regime inside the Muslim Brotherhood the
pro Iranian the salafis I think we
should zoom on these four which are
creating that problem all right thank
you all for being with us appreciate
your expertise and you can see on the
other side of the screens those were the
first pictures from Charlie uh ebdo
where you can see the blood inside of
the office building with this Carnage
and this evil took place now we have a
busy news night tonight how some in the
western media are giving radical Muslims
a pass Mark Stein is here to respond to
that tonight with his analysis plus
tonight here on Hannity